[Applause]
[Music]
This is
it I want this I can't give up Why don't you give up Why
get everything you want You're
my successor And a football player
can only be a chosen person
Be a first class businessman They're doing it for you
These guys gave me
not what I want
I'm gonna make this school a national champion And
shut them up
World Cup  After that
, my super heart is like this, so the soccer club
got drunk What should I
do?
I
'm a son of a rich man Give me money
I don't play soccer I
've never played sports I
want to laze around for the rest of my life
Let's
do it Do your best It's not a dream to be a professional You can't do without a
sign
Football is troublesome I hate trouble I
don't want to work I
can only be a chosen person
Hey here a
chosen person
life was full of boredom
Let's play
soccer Until I met Kiyoshiro Nagi